you. Hello Hey, Alexandra.
All right. Whoa Your camera
looks super green. What'd you
do? Oh, it's the backlighting.
I alternate between blue, green
and red. Okay, cool, cool. Um.
Fun to have a green tint. Yeah
I mean, I don't know if it's
green. Well it's blue and, you
know, otherwise, it's great.
What is green? Just Oh, neutral.
Okay I'll take it. Green Green
is I get to work with very
talented players to prepare
them for a tournament. For sure.
For sure. Um I am actually
playing Iceland. I'm excited.
Have you ever played? Rake of
it? Yes Oh, Rick of a coping.
Yes I played in 2015 just once.
Okay Okay. And how is it? You
like? I played once before, too,
and I was like, Oh, my God.
I was like, Oh, my God. It's
like an experience. Just
landing in the airport. Your
mouth is like, Oh, my God.
Obviously the weather is
something to get used to. I
still have a screenshot of my
phone. The wind one of the days
was 100 km per hour. It was
very hard to get to the playing
hall, which was 10 steps from
the hotel. It was literally
walking through the wind. You
were walking and you literally
had to grab on to like rail it,
and it was just normal when I
played. It wasn't so bad. I
mean, it feels like March.
April is a good time for
Iceland. But I guess you know,
you know, you never know what's
gonna happen with the weather.
You never know. But the
tournament itself like the
organization, obviously, as you
would expect from Iceland is
impeccable. The fish is some
obviously don't go to a
tournament for the restaurants,
although I kind of do. The
seafood is like, you know,
mouthwatering. It's
incredible. So definitely like
get the fish. I don't know if
you're a fish eater. Food was
so at the hotel I was staying
when I played. There was this
pizza that was potato leak pizza
and it's one of the best pizzas
I've ever had. I don't know why
it was so good because they made
the potatoes super crispy, so it
adds a crunch and then they
added some little sauce on top
of the leak and it was amazing.
It was so many weird
combinations of foods, but I
love them. I don't think I've
ever had a potato on pizza, but
I'm not a big fish eater, by
the way, and and I said it was
amazing. I'll have to try.
So where would you recommend
getting food from? Fish plate of
yours? It was a I wouldn't
remember like the because it was
there was a weird setup where
they gave me like vouchers, but
you could only use them at
certain restaurants. Oh yeah, I
don't think that too. I did get
pizza on the following day. I
think most of the restaurants I
went to there are really good.
Obviously, like Reykjavik is a
Reykjavik is a super expensive
city, but yeah, basically, I
don't think I had a single bad
like day in in Reykjavik. Damn,
that's awesome. My best friend
is actually flying out at the
end of the tournament and we're
going to explore for a few days
after so I'm actually going to
be a tourist, which is going to
be awesome. Last time I didn't
explore. No, absolutely. You
should go to the like Blue
Geysers or whatever they're
called. There's the famous Blue
Lagoon. I went to the Blue
Lagoon with Anna Rudolph last
time. It was nice, but I thought
it was a little bit overrated
overblown local. Yeah, I'm
going to ask the locals where
they go. It was near some
factories and it felt like it
was a you know, an artificial
Lagoon. It was still nice and
it had a spa, but I want to go
where the locals go this time. I
see. I see keep you updated.
Please do. I'll be following
your games obviously, but it's a
nice tournament. I think you'll
have a good time. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. I'm
excited. Okay, let's quickly
set up everything. Do you want
to send me the invite for sure?
Would you like me to put to turn
on my camera on discord and
disable it on my stream or how
what set up would you prefer?
Or are you going to just your
camera? I can totally do that.
If you want, we could just
yoink each other's cameras
after. That's fine with me.
Okay, I'm down to keep it
simple. Let's do that. I'm
inviting you now. I've got some
cool material. So, um, first
things first, I have to give
you this warm up exercise. It's
I had a hard time solving this.
So I'm going to give it to me.
So I'm gonna but there's a
caveat. It's not just a regular
tactic. Just okay. Just send you
the invite. Okay. Um, hang on.
Let me accept. It's loading. I
said, Yes. Awesome. Oh, I think
it's just taking a second. Yeah.
Okay. Um, well, before we get
into it, maybe we introduce the
four. I'll introduce the format
quickly one more time for
anybody who's new. You guys
know, this is Grandmaster
Naroditsky. I am around master
level strength. So we basically
do these training exercise so
you can see the difference in
thinking. We're also going to
give you guys time in the chat
so you could think about it. Um
and if you want to see Daniel's
point of view, I linked his
twitch stream in the chat.
Awesome. That was a very
succinct description. Obviously
I, as I mentioned on my stream,
some of the exercises are are
challenging. So you know, people
shouldn't expect, you know, made
into actually, they should
expect made in Tuesdays. We're
about to see. Uh, but the point
here is to challenge ourselves
and expand our thinking. And
hopefully people in the chat
will will be able to do the
same. So this kind of blew my
mind. It was given to me by a
friend. It's white to play and
made in three moves. Wow. Um
made in three. There's no it's
not one of those. You know, I
hate those troll problems. Oh,
you got a castle and or you got
to like move your king to a
seven tilting. I hate those.
It's actual made in three. Um
so I'll give you some time to
think about it. White spawns.
Obviously you should face white
whites going up. And black is
currently stalemated. So, uh,
that's sort of your jumping off
point. Okay. Um, do you want me
to mute myself as I think out
loud? Or do you want me to just
think? And then you totally your
choice. I'll let you think in
peace so you can think aloud.
And, uh, you know, I'll let you
I'll let you get off the ground,
and then maybe I could add some
some things along the way.
Perfect So maybe I'll think out
loud and then you can correct or
see anything that I miss. Um,
obviously, it's gonna be a
little bit slower if I do that,
but I think it's better anyway
for people watching. No worries.
Mm hmm. Okay, cool. So as
Dania said, I'm going to be
So as Dania said, black doesn't
have any moves here, even though
we're up, you know, three pieces.
Um, so the obvious way to start
thinking about these is to just
start. Oh, do you mind giving me
arrow privileges? No, I'll think
about it. They're just gonna
give full control. There you go.
Thank you. Thank you. Okay. Any
other requests? Alexander is so
demanding. I mean, Jesus, send
me a coffee, please. I need more
caffeine. Um, okay. Night of
eight. Bishop G eight. Those are
the checks we see right away.
The other ideas I could go for
if it's stalemate is, you know,
to move one of the pieces like
night at four so that I give
black an option. I don't love
that, though, because then you
have to start calculating all
the pawn pushes as well. Um,
okay, so I'm gonna sit here for
a second and actually, I'm just
gonna start thinking through
the checks. Okay, so there's
Bishop G eight. King takes, uh,
which looks forced right now
check. And then the problem with
that is that the king goes back.
You can't meet because he takes
the night. So that's probably
not a made in three. Okay, then
there's nine of eight check. He
plays King H eight. Um, and then
the only check I have that isn't
repeating the position would be
rook takes H six pawn takes and
that doesn't end in me either.
So the first two checks seem to
not work. Um, okay. What else?
So we've ruled out Knight F eight
and Bishop G eight have been
ruled out. Yep, exactly. So the
immediate checks don't work. Um,
okay, next options. I talked
about moving the night and
there's also moving the bishop
so that we're not actually
still meeting. So, uh, for
example, there's the idea of
Bishop E eight, which forces
King to G eight. Um, then what
am I going to do from there? Is
there anything? Rook F six, but
even GF just takes or even King
H seven, even King H seven.
Neither of those work. Um, so,
so I could go deeper into this,
but as of right now, I don't
think Bishop E eight works.
Nope. Yeah, you're right.
Because you ultimately need like
a target target baiting
position. And with the Bishop on
the gate, the only way to
checkmate the King on H seven is
to get the rook to H eight. And
that just seems unfeasible
because you'll have to go
through stalemate. Exactly. Um,
okay, cool. So the only other
way to not keep him stalemated
is to move the night unless I'm
missing something, but that's
what I see so far. Um, and the
old options for the night we
ruled out night of fate. So
then the only two options are
night of four and 95. There is
one more by the way. And night
H eight. Oh my God. If it's
night H eight, I don't think it
is though. Cause there's no
mating position from there or
is there cause there is
technically night H eight King
takes Bishop G six King here
and checkmate. So actually I do
need to look at night H eight
as well. Uh, that you, what
you're doing right now is
exactly how I approached this
position and night H eight was
my first attempt. Okay. Um,
okay. So, but, but then the
other issue with night H eight
is what if, you know, the
G five, let's say, yeah,
exactly. Um, and then I don't,
if you're not taking the night,
there's no mating position, no
maiden too. And in fact, you
can extend this to all of the
night moves, night at four G
five, 95 G five. We should show
that on the board for people
because my chat is excited at
night H eight. I'll let you
play it out. So what I think
studies teach you, because you
might be looking at saying who
gives a damn a maiden three
you're up a hundred pieces. It
teaches you a, to be stubborn
and B to, if you're not taking
the night, there's no mating
position. So if you're not
taking the night, it teaches you
a, to be stubborn and B to
reinforces you to consider all
of the opponent's resources,
which I think is the primary,
uh, instructive, um, sort of
value of these types of
positions. So if King takes H
eight, you drop the Bishop down
and it's made. The problem is
that black doesn't have to
cooperate. G five opens up a
square and it's made in four, I
think, but not made in three.
So like check even takes, and
there's no made on the next
move. You have to go here and
this is already three moves and
this is four moves. Okay. So we
got to get it exactly three
moves, exactly three moves. So
all night moves have been ruled
out. All right. So no more
night moves. Um, and I guess we
need to go, let me think if
there's anything else that,
well, that wouldn't be
stalemate. Oh, a move like Rook
F six. Okay. Oh, six is an
interesting idea. You're giving
up the Rook in order to grant
black more moves. And then you
play King F eight, but you don't
get Bishop G eight because then
your Knight isn't protected.
Yes, but you're on an
interesting track. Are there any
other ways to sack the Rook, for
example? Right. And there are,
there's Rook A two. Okay. Um,
Rook A two, but, but first let
me see if there is a way to even
check with, to checkmate with
the Bishop and the Knight. Um,
I mean, if you didn't have a
Rook here, you couldn't check
me as far as I see. Okay. So
that is the human assumption.
That is the human. Okay. So
maybe there's a way to make.
Um, look very carefully after
Rook A two B takes A two. Your
brain is telling you this makes
no logical sense to give up the
Rook. How could there be an
additional pattern when the Rook
is off the board? I don't know.
Yeah, that's exactly what my
brain is saying, Dania. But
force yourself to consider, like
ask yourself, what are the new
moves that you have in that
position that you wouldn't have
previously? Um, well, the pawn
is way too slow, so we're not
going to try to do that. Uh,
now the cool thing is that
black has an extra move, so we
don't have to worry about
stalemate. True. Um, there's no
mating pattern with the bishop
in the night and the black king
on H seven. Yeah, let's make
the moves on the board. Okay.
There is no mating. You'll have
you're about to have a light
bulb moment and you're gonna be
like, Oh my gosh, you're gonna
hate me after this. Oh, God.
Um. Oh, I see it. That's very
cute. That's very cute. It's
very pretty. Yeah. So you take
the pawn. I'll play it out and
then black takes G six and then
forced. That's ridiculous, but
it's very beautiful. It's
beautiful. I could not get it,
so I needed I needed to know the
first move. I mean, yeah, the
human sentiment here is like,
Oh, there's no way to make
because you've already looked at
it before, so you're not
considering the change in
position with B takes a two.
Right, exactly. And so much of
like thinking is developing the
ability to detect small details
and how they impact the
position. Yeah, that's this is
very cute. I'm going to turn
this into a short. Oh,
absolutely. I mean, look at the
crazy. You have to give up the
rook in the night, and that's
the only way to checkmate.
Damn. Um, that's a very cute
puzzle. Thank you for sharing
it. Yeah, I figured we'd start
with this one to sort of set the
tone, and I know it's like
brutally difficult. It is, but
it's so pretty. So it's I think
it's worth it. Yeah, I feel like
if you give people difficult
tactics, it has to be beautiful.
So at least you feel good when
it's over. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. Um, okay, so I have a
lot of cool material starting
position one more time.
Definitely came in late, and
then definitely so before we go
into the actual exercises, the
rest of them, which, Daniel,
you haven't seen the next
exercises, right? You're also
going to be working. That's
right. Okay, good. Good. Um,
yeah, so it was checkmate in
three from this position. White
to move. Okay, cool. Back to
you. Yeah, checkmate in three
from this move, and, uh, people
who came in late can do the
thinking on their own. So I'm
thinking we should do one more
warm up exercise. This is
supposed to be a little bit on
the easier side. Where this
comes from is, uh, a book
called The Manual of Chess
Combinations Volume two. Now I
did some of these puzzles about
you know, 10 years ago, so I
don't remember a single one of
them. I promise. I don't know
the solution to any of the
exercises that we're about to
do. So we're going to start
with an endgame study. That's a
little bit less outlandish than
the one we just solved. Wait.
All right. This was the easy
one. No, no, this was this was
on the harder side for sure.
The next one that I'm about to
paste in, I think is supposed
to be a little bit a little bit
more straightforward. So I just
pasted it in. It is sorry. Can
you give me a second? I just
realized I don't. I'm not going
to have your audio in the VOD,
so I'm fixing it now. Oh, OK.
OK, no worries. It's OK. I'll
take it from yours. Alright,
we're good. Alright, so this is
white to play and win. White to
play and win. At least this one
is more interesting. Because
you're down material, but you
have decimating chances. And
you know that you know you know
this one or you have? No, no,
no, no, no. I don't. I don't
know the solution to this one.
I'm solving. OK, so should we
do that thing where we think for
23 minutes and then we talk out
loud? Yes, I think we should do
that. Oh, shoot. Sorry, I have
somebody who's who's coming to
help me unpack and I forgot and
I left her locked up. No
worries. Go do your thing. No
rush at all. One second. Take
your time. No rush. So I'm
gonna I'm gonna start thinking
in the meantime. I'm gonna mute
myself in Discord. Actually,
no, I want Alex's people to
hear me. So it's white to play
and win. White's pawns are going
this way, folks. What's going on
here? Well, the Black King is
checkmated. So I would suppose
the target position involves
getting the Rook around to H2.
The most obvious move to me is
Rook F4 or Rook F2. I'm
actually gonna mute myself in
Discord so Alex's folks can
think on their own. Um how is
Black going to defend after
Rook F2? Well, Rook H2 is
unstoppable. Black can move the
King up to H5. So that tells me
Rook F4 prevents King H5
because then Rook H4 is still
checkmate. Rook F4, the only
move I think is Bishop to D1.
Hmm. Only move is Bishop to D1
to block the check. I'm gonna
put I'm gonna put a timer or
did you already start thinking?
I started a little bit but but
you should put a timer. Okay.
And I will mute myself in
Discord so I can think aloud on
my own stream. Perfect. Alright.
Alright. I'm putting it up.
Here we go. Good luck. Alright.
So, where were we? We were
considering and I won't draw
arrows cuz Alex will see them.
Rook F4, Bishop D1, Rook H4
check, Bishop H5, G4, Rook F3.
So the White King is pushed
away there. Huh. Rook F4,
Bishop D1. I feel like Bishop E2.
I feel like Bishop E2 somewhere
is gonna be winning. But where?
Rook F2, Bishop D1. Huh. Rook F4,
Bishop D1. Just make sure this
is the right position. Yeah, it
is. Okay. Rook F4, Bishop D1,
Rook H4, Bishop H5, Bishop E2,
Rook takes E2. Rook F2, Bishop D1.
It had, there had some, gonna be
some bishop move at some point
that intercepts Black's Rook.
Where? F4, Bishop D1. Well, you
can't start with Bishop E2
because the Rook is hanging.
Can't start with Bishop E2
because the Rook is hanging. So
it has to be a move of the Rook.
Rook F2, Bishop D1, Rook H2,
Rook H2, Bishop H5. Oh, I got it.
Oh my god. I think I got it.
It's Rook F2, Bishop D1, Rook H2,
Bishop H5, Bishop E2. Force the Rook
onto E2 and then go G4 and it's
mate with G5 because Black can't
give the check on the F file
anymore. If he does, then we take
the Rook. The Bishop takes the
pawn. Rook H2, Bishop H5. And in
that position, okay, I got it.
There you can basically force
Zugzwang. You can just wait until
Black gives up the E pawn. Yeah,
okay, I got it. That is insane.
We will, folks, obviously when we
reconvene, we're going to make
all the moves on the board. So if
you're watching this and you're
lost, don't worry because we will
make the moves on the board. What
I'm doing now is giving you a
window into how I actually think
about these types of exercises,
which hopefully is, you know,
interesting. Yeah, I think it's
Rook F2, Bishop D1, Rook H2,
Bishop H5. Then the point is
Black is threatening Rook F3
check. So you have to deflect the
Rook onto a square such that the
Rook will not be able to check
the White King. On the F file,
Bishop E2, Rook takes E2, and
then the key is to see the pawn
mate with G5. So it's definitely
Rook F2. It's not Rook F4. Okay,
I'm going to pause. It's almost
three minutes. Sorry, I was
thinking chat. I was thinking in
my head. Okay, so I notice
obviously we're trying to
checkmate the Black King, so
ideas like Rook F4 and Rook F2
with the idea of trying to
checkmate. I looked at the line
Rook F2, King H5, Bishop E2, and
then after Black takes, Rook
takes. I mean, this looks pretty
good for White, but... Yeah, it's
50-50 type of position. Yeah,
exactly, because it feels like
Black can trade off for G3, and
then this is going to be a draw.
So I think... It seemed like it
wasn't good enough. I agree
completely. After King H5, I
think there is a clean mate
here, because it's important, I
think, to detect small
differences. So I looked at this
for a second, and I realized
that... Well, what is Black's
alternate defensive method here?
What is the only other move?
I just saw it, because it's King
H5, and then Rook F4. Bingo.
Rook F4, we should probably play
it out. Now Black has no way to
block the checkmate on H4, so
Rook takes G3, eliminating the
support of the H4 square is the
only move, and now Bishop E2
check forces Black to give up
the Rook. Otherwise, it's
checkmate. Right. On H4.
Interesting. So this is
basically combining what you
learn with... When you look at
this position, because you're
also considering Rook F4, but
then the problem is Bishop D1,
and you're blocking on H5, so
what you're trying to do is get
the King there to block the
square first. Right. But of
course, after Rook F2, I
thought the sort of other
defense here was Bishop D1
anyway. Mm-hmm. And did you
consider this, or were you more
focused on King H5? Um... Oh, I
thought Rook F2 didn't work.
Oh, because of King H5. Yeah.
I gotcha. So... Sorry, sorry,
sorry. No, no, no. I thought
Rook F2 didn't work because of
Bishop D1. Oh, okay, okay. So I
think... Which is why the other
variation seems to fix it.
Which is Rook F4? Yes. So how
do things work after Rook F4?
I play Bishop D1. And what was
your intention here? Because
Rook H4 is still Bishop H5,
right? Yeah. Yeah, right. It's
still a problem. And I think
it's a bit of a dead end. So I
think it is Rook F2. I think it
is Rook F2. And after Bishop D1,
what is like the most tempting
idea? What are the two moves
that they seem to win the game
if you look very superficially?
Stuff like Rook H2, G4.
Exactly. So that's what I
started with. Yeah. Right. But
yeah. Sorry, go ahead. I'll play
it out on the board so people
can see what we're talking
about. So this is the idea that
obviously you want to look at
first. But then after Rook F3
check, you're pushing the King
away. So I don't see how we're
going to end up better here
because you just trade. You end
up trading everything. And it's
a draw. In fact, Black is
playing for the win there. Yeah,
okay. Wait, why is Black playing
for the win here? Well, not
really. But I mean, I'm
threatening Rook F4. I can see
White losing this in a
Okay, fair, fair. If White loses
the G-pawn, then it gets
complicated. Of course, White
should play King E5. Yeah,
obviously. Right, Chad? Of
course, of course. Why? I mean,
well, I mean, to be completely
honest here, you know, you know
what White is playing for the
win. But, you know, with that
being said, so in any case,
after Bishop H5, I think it's a
critical position. Okay. After
Black blocks the check.
Okay. Because here, you know,
you're pushing the King away.
Because here, I sort of tried to
problem solve. Like, is there a
way to forcibly prevent Rook F2?
Oh my god. Yeah, you got it.
Bishop E2. I love the light
bubble. Yeah, Bishop E2 is
right. Wow, this is another cute
one. Bishop E2, Rook takes E2.
And then you push G4. Yeah, I
think that's what it is. It
goes on. Rook F2, I thought
Rook takes F2. Yup. Bishop G4.
And then Bishop takes G4. So,
Rook H2 check, of course,
Bishop H5. And here, I generated
a target position, which is that
here's the thing. If Black's
E-pawn is gone, then I think
White has a winning move, which
is to step down to F5. Yup, and
give Black the runaway square so
that you can take the Bishop.
So, my second answer, yeah. So,
you have to force the E-pawn to
be given away. Mm-hmm. I was
going to say, I want Black to
work the way your brain does.
I don't know if that's the case.
I think if you see how my brain
works, you'll be like, I don't
know about this thing. You get
the chess GM, but, you know, you
always break a few mouses here
and there. That's exactly
right. So, how do we get rid of
the E-pawn without allowing
Black out of the cage? Okay,
well, that is a bit of a
predicament. Okay, so let's say
we're just keeping the Rook on
the H-file. Mm-hmm. And then he
keeps pushing. At what point
would it be okay for us to take
the Pawn? And we have to do it
with the Rook. Yup, yup. It
feels like if the Pawn's on E3,
we should be able to take it,
because then, oh, no, oh,
because we need to be able to
come back with check. Okay, so
we basically need to take it on
a light square, then. Agree 100%.
And you can take it on E4.
Yup, you can take it on E4,
exactly. So, something like
this. Bingo. And then,
wherever the Bishop moves, it
doesn't matter, because you have
that check back. He goes here,
he makes space for the King, and
then you win. I think that's
what it is. Wow, this is a
pretty tactic. Very. How long
did it take you to find it?
Most of the... I was stumped the
first, like, minute and a half.
I was like, okay, this is a
I was stumped the first, like,
minute and a half. I kept... I
knew that Bishop E2 was probably
involved, because it's also like
a classic study motif. So, the
position after Bishop H5 stumped
me for a while. Sorry, I'm
gonna let you put it back there.
No worries. The third move,
Bishop E2, is what took me the
longest. And I honestly think
one of the reasons I solve these
is just I'm, like, stubborn as
hell. And in certain critical
positions, I just refuse to
admit that the line doesn't
work. I've noticed this in my
lessons as well. I don't think
it's that I see more tactical
patterns. I mean, I maybe see
them more quickly, but I think
I'm a lot more stubborn. I think
I'm a lot less inclined to give
up on a line, just in general.
Interesting. Well, yeah, I mean,
in three minutes, I couldn't go
super deep in the lines, but I
haven't... I think I asked you
about this before, but when
you're calculating lines, do you
look at all of them kind of
surface, and then go... and then
you go deeper into the ones you
like? But do you come back to
your lines, or do you try to
solve it all the way through the
first time you're on it? I would
say two things. I do try to solve
it all the way through if I see
a promising first move. Like, if
I see a move that seems
promising, I will... I won't, you
know, start looking at the other
candidate moves until I've
exhausted the line. But what I
also try to do is when I
consider other candidate moves,
I try to extract information
from a line that doesn't work.
I don't think people do this
enough. Like, you calculate a
line that fails, but you know,
in that line, you might have
discovered an interesting idea
that could be applied in a
different first candidate move.
So, for instance, you might have
been calculating, you know, rook
f4, and maybe in this line, you
spotted the idea of advancing
the g-pawn to g5 with checkmate.
And then, of course, the same
idea is applied in this
position, so a lot of lines are
connected, and you have to
extract information even from
lines that fail, I think.
That makes sense, and that's why
the bishop e2 is so key, because
the problem with any of those
variations was that black would
get some kind of check on f3, so
that was the only way to not get
that.
Exactly. Exactly. Are you up for
one more endgame study, or
should we go to the middle game?
I love endgame studies.
Me too. So, let's do one.
They're awesome.
We're in agreement.
Let's do more.
I feel like the one I'm setting
up right now can be either, like,
really easy or really hard.
Let's see which one it is.
White to play in white.
White to play and win.
Okay.
Here it is.
I don't see it yet, but I'll let
it come up on the board.
Ooh.
White to play and win?
Let's do this thing.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to think for three
minutes, and then I will start
talking again.
Same here.
I'll mute myself in Discord.
Okay.
Perfect.
All right.
Let's do this thing.
So, what do I see?
Oh.
Obviously, if we take the rook,
black plays bishop f2 check and
wins our rook, and that's a draw.
First move I see is rook to e8
check, but then the king moves
to f7 and hits our rook, and if
we go rook b8 there, then black
always has this check on f2.
Are there any other checks?
Bishop c4 check.
What we could try to do is get
the rook on a light square with
check so that we could pick up
black's rook and we don't lose
our own.
So, bishop c4 check.
If the king moves to f8, then
rook f1 wins.
If the king moves to h8, then
rook e8 check wins.
So, bishop c4 check.
Where can black go?
King g7.
Rook e7 check.
Okay.
I got to think here.
King f8.
Rook f7 check.
King e8.
Huh.
King h5.
Let's see.
Bishop c4, king g7.
Rook e7, king f8.
Doesn't seem too promising.
What about rook e8 check?
Rook e8 check, king f7.
No, I don't like that either.
Let's go back to bishop c4,
king g7.
I just got to think in silence.
Oh, I think I got it.
I think I got it.
Wait.
Check there, there.
I think I got it.
Yeah.
So, I think it is bishop c4 check.
King g7.
Rook e7 check.
There is also king f6.
That has to be considered.
Then rook e6 check.
King f5.
And you just move your king.
That's got to be winning.
So, bishop c4 check.
King g7.
Rook e7 check.
King f8.
Rook f7 check.
King e8.
I think it's rook f6.
Bishop d8.
Bishop b5 check.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that's it.
It's not like a beautiful tactic,
but there is a very pretty theme in the middle there.
Yeah.
So, I think it's bishop c4.
King g7.
Rook e7.
King f8.
Rook f7.
King e8.
And then I think the critical move that's easy to miss is rook back to f6,
hitting the bishop, but then there's bishop d8,
pinning the rook against the king.
And then white has the intermediate move, bishop b5 check.
So, I think that's the critical idea.
This is more like, you know,
this is less quote-unquote nice than the previous one,
but I think it's super instructive.
All right.
Three minutes is up.
Okay.
So, I see that we're attacking the rook.
We can't take right away because bishop f2 checking the rook and the king.
And ultimately, the other important thing about this position is
even if we somehow win a pawn,
it's still probably going to be a draw if we trade off rooks.
So, then the question is, is there any way to get out of this check?
And the most promising line looked like something bishop c4.
100%.
The king can't go to f8 because you check and you take the rook.
The king can't go to h8 because you check on e8 and then you take the rook.
So, the only option is king g7.
And I was working on figuring this out all the way through,
but I think this is a position I started getting stuck at.
Yep.
So, so far, I'm in agreement.
So, here I thought rook e6 check is logical.
And I think there's two difficult spots in this study.
So, king f5.
Black has to keep contact with the rook.
Again, I think it's important not to be stubborn in regards to the goal
because I formulated the goal as winning black's rook,
but winning the bishop is also a way to win the game.
I think if you think of it that way, the move is very clear.
You just need to step out of the check, basically.
That's disturbing.
Yes, I see it now.
You're right.
So, what move do you think it is here?
Because I think there's a trap you have to avoid.
Okay, yeah.
So, we don't want bishop f2 and we also don't want to play rook h5
and have rook a1 work.
Excellent.
So, then you have to play king h3.
You have to play king h3.
Black can try h5, but now I think a simple move
reinforces the threat of bishop takes a6.
Let's see.
Where do we want to move our rook?
We want to move our rook somewhere where the king can't attack it.
So, the only square is e6.
So, this position is winning for sure because black's rook
can't move away with the check.
You make it seem so easy.
But there's another line, by the way.
That was close.
And I felt like I was close, but I didn't make it all the way
to the end yet.
You totally would with like an additional two minutes.
So, I feel like you're getting the crux of this.
There's also the king f8, which has to be considered.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
So, let's take a look at that one too.
So, king f8 and I mean, the moves that I think you have
to consider here are, I mean, it has to be rook f7.
Yes.
Oh, rook f7 and then the king isn't going to move to g8
because there's discovery.
So, he moves e6 and then rook f6.
Bishop d8.
Oh, bishop d8.
You're right.
Nope.
So, you need to be careful.
Wait, but remember stubbornness.
You know, you don't abandon the line.
Never abandon the line.
Rook f6, bishop d8.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Okay.
Bishop b5 check, forcing the king.
Oh, it's disgustingly beautiful.
It's amazing.
Bishop b5 check is, I think, the key move in this line.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
That's very cute.
Don't abandon lines.
God, I love these studies that have...
The beauty is of a different kind than the previous one,
I think.
It is.
No, these are just so satisfying at the end.
They really are.
Yeah, okay.
So, I mean, you solved this one,
and your big switch was realizing that
you could just win the bishop.
Yes, that was the first biggest thing,
which is that I wasn't in my mind saying
if I don't win the rook, it's lost.
I understood that if you get a situation like this
and you can force the black rook to move,
it's important also to realize that the white bishop
is defending the pawn.
Because if black could win the pawn,
rook and bishop versus rook is a draw.
If black wins the pawn on the board,
it's totally winning.
And then the second thing was the stubbornness
to find bishop b5 check.
That makes sense.
And, yeah, I think that's one thing
when you're calculating a plan,
you know, until you're a grandmaster
or a very strong player,
it's easy to tunnel on one thing
you're trying to do.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
But broadening the goal is super important.
Yes.
Yeah, that makes sense.
This was a cute one.
I love endgame studies.
They're very fun.
Want to do one more endgame study?
Let's do it.
All right, so...
I want to find one.
I just want to get one.
No, you're getting the right moves in all of them.
I think three minutes is just not a lot of time
for solving studies,
but I still think we're, you know,
producing instructive value.
Yeah, and we're making progress.
Totally.
And I think this next one...
You know what I feel like?
You know when you're in the gym
and you're lifting a weight
and you can't lift it anymore
and then you have somebody
who helps you bring it all the way to the top?
Yeah, spotter.
That's what you're getting
from my mental exercises.
Yeah.
I just don't believe in, like,
super easy exercises.
As satisfying as it is,
like, what is the instructive value
of doing puzzles
that you can get in, like, ten seconds?
You know, the interesting thing
is that you said
you should do puzzles
that are 300 ELO
above your chess.com puzzle rating,
and Hammer says 300 ELO below.
Ooh.
So it's an interesting contradiction there.
Very interesting.
I mean, my caveat is that,
of course, you should do warm-up exercises
and there should be some time
dedicated to just maintenance
of your skills,
but I was speaking about
the sort of main phase
of your training.
But there's many methods.
It's okay.
I'm not trying to start beef.
Oh, you should start beef
between you and Don.
No, I think it's great.
Sorry, beef between you and Hammer.
Okay.
So this is it.
Wait to play and win.
Mm-hmm.
I see people in my chat
asking for his camera.
We have his stream title,
his stream name in the title.
You can click on it
and you can see both.
Okay, cool.
So should we do the thing
where we think for three minutes?
Wait, you said wait to move and win?
Yes.
I'm as surprised as you are.
Yeah, that's...
Oh, okay.
All right.
Good luck.
I'm gonna start the timer.
Let's do this.
Okay, so there's two ways
to win this game.
There's Checkmate
and you need to win the Queen,
but you can't let Black
recapture the Rook.
Okay, so Rook d1 is ruled out.
Black's King moves aside
and if you take the Queen,
then only Black
can win that position.
So I feel like
it has to be Knight c7 check.
That's the only move
which makes sense.
So if King d4,
then we fork with the Knight.
If King e5,
then we go Rook e1 check.
If King f6,
then there's another fork on e8.
So the King has to go to f4.
Knight e6 check
forces the King to g4.
Ah, but then if we go Rook g1 check,
Black has Queen g3.
Aye.
Okay, that doesn't work.
Crap.
I thought that was it.
Hmm.
Knight c7,
King e5,
Rook e1,
King f4.
Knight e6,
King g4,
Rook g1,
Queen g3.
Maybe we found a mistake
in the exercise.
Wait a minute.
If it's not that,
then what on earth is it?
Maybe it's a mistake in the study
because if Black didn't have Queen g3,
then it would be winning for White.
Maybe it's some sort of Zugzwang?
No, I don't think so.
I think this might be a flawed study.
I think this might be a flawed study,
which is very instructive
in its own right, by the way.
Holy smokes.
Let's see if Alex is stumped
on the same idea.
This would be awesome.
Yeah, I think it's wrong.
I think it's wrong.
Alexandra,
I gotta cut you off for a second.
Okay.
I think this is a flawed study,
but I'm curious
if you're stumped
on the same move that I am.
I'm deep into variation right now.
I can tell you where I've gotten.
Yeah, tell me where you're gotten
because I'm deep into variation
and I think this is a mistake
in the study.
I've confirmed.
This is the right position.
Okay.
So, I mean,
I was looking into this line.
Yeah.
Knight's d7.
I'm just gonna play the line
that I thought was the one
that was the most tricky.
Yeah.
Getting into this position here.
And then I was looking at check
and it works at King h5,
but I was trying to figure out
what to do after King h3.
Here it works as well.
Which I see a draw.
But there is a mate there.
There is a mate there.
Yeah, there is a mate there.
Okay, well, this is where
I had gotten.
But there's something crazy,
which is that in this position,
black has a move
that refutes the line.
Queen g3.
I think.
I didn't even think about that yet.
I think this was missed
by the composer of the study.
I'll check the solution,
but you should find
the mate after King h3.
Okay.
Yeah, this is where I was.
Oh, I, I, I.
Uh, almost.
Okay, let me find it.
People in my chat confirming
this is winning for black,
actually, after Queen g3.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
Take your time.
Yeah, so check.
Check.
King h2.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I see it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very cute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, but this is where
I was without moving the pieces.
So I was just trying
to figure out King h3
because I had seen
the lines until then,
but I also missed Queen g3.
And so did the study composer.
This is vkoshek1906,
and I'm reading the solution,
and the solution misses Queen g3.
Damn.
Wow.
I mean, you know,
it was 1906.
We'll give him a break.
So I'm gonna circle this
because there are some people
who collect wrong studies.
So I'm gonna write.
I'm gonna note this down.
That's an extremely nerdy.
Oh, my God.
Definitely is.
It's like you leveled up solving.
You don't just do chess.
You don't just do chess puzzles,
but you correct them.
Yeah, it was wrong.
Like, I looked at the study,
and he missed a move.
So it's invalid.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
That's very funny.
You know what that means, though.
What does that mean?
That means we gotta do
hopefully one that has
a proper solution.
Yeah.
I was so close.
I felt like I was gonna
finally get an endgame study.
But that's so amazing
how the study composer,
it's the power of your brain
like making assumptions, right?
Like, oh, the king has to move
in response to rook g3.
That's a whole other topic,
which is the importance
of like not letting your brain
kind of dictate, you know,
push you around
and really pausing
on every position.
No, that's true.
And then when you're
solving the puzzle,
you know there's a solution.
So you're just going through
what you think the solution
would look like.
Mm-hmm.
Which is why, you know,
training puzzles and puzzles
in real life is always
so different.
Oh, 100%.
And I think our next set
of exercises is really
going to help address that.
But let's do one more study.
Okay.
White to play and...
Let me see.
And win.
Okay.
All right.
You know, you are making
it a little easier
because you could have
just said white to play.
Sure.
But I'll take it.
But I also am saying
it wouldn't be fair
because I'm seeing plus minus
in the book.
Yeah.
So we want to make it fair.
All right.
Good luck.
Perfect.
Thank you.
You too.
All right.
What do I see here?
Well, we could take the knight
but then black takes B2
and that seems like
an unclear position.
Probably white is better
but it's not going
to be totally winning.
Rook B4 comes to mind
because you can't take the rook.
Queen C8.
Rook B8.
You can't take the rook again.
So where does the queen
go after Rook B4,
Queen C8, Rook B8?
Well, it has to go to H3.
Then there's Rook H8.
The queen has no squares
but black can go Knight H4.
Wait.
Black can go Knight H4.
Rook takes H4.
Black can go Queen C8
and then you go to H8 again.
Queen B7.
Rook B8.
Oh, that's unreal.
You do that six times
and you trap the queen.
Oh, that's so pretty.
Rook takes H4.
Queen C8.
Rook H8.
Queen B7.
Rook B8.
Queen A7.
Knight C6 check.
You have to chase the queen
around the entire board
using the technique
of sacking your rook
because the rook
can't be taken
due to a fork
on C6 or on G6.
Yeah, I mean it's a concept
that everybody
should be familiar with
and I know this concept
from studies
so it's not hard
because I've solved
a million of these studies.
Maybe you have as well
where you have to
chase a queen around
with a rook
that's constantly hanging
and it can't be captured.
So this is an easier one
because it's the same theme
for every move.
That is really pretty.
Really pretty.
Phenomenal.
I'm already looking
at the next one we could do.
I think I got it.
Let's hear it.
Okay, so
I think it's rook B4.
Agree.
You can't play queen A7
because of knight C6.
If you play queen A8
then you play rook B8.
Either move,
you're going to play knight C6.
You're up enough pawns
so that's winning.
So of course
the more testing line
is queen C8.
Rook B8.
Similar idea
but then the black queen
has this escape square
but then it looks like
rook H8 works
because there's nowhere
the queen can run.
Right, but there's knight H4.
Nowhere here, nowhere here.
There is knight H4
which
I hadn't seen yet.
And
can you just take this
or is there an issue?
Oh, if you take
I guess the queen
can go back.
Keep going.
And then if the queen
goes back
you have
probably H3.
Because you should be stubborn.
Oh, you put your rook back.
Yes.
And the queen runs again.
Why is this queen
always running?
And then you put
the rook on B8.
Yes!
It's a beautiful study.
Jesus, this is
a lot of queen running
around the board.
I should probably
play it out.
Play it on the board, yeah.
Okay, so
you can't take
because there's this fork
so the queen runs away
but you say
not so fast
and you go
rook H8
but the queen has
another square
and that's
when you play
again.
Yeah.
The rook goes back
and then this looks beautiful.
You know
what's incredible
about this study?
Who composes these?
What's incredible?
This was
I'll tell you who composed it.
It was
let me check
the number
of the puzzle
it's 5
I'm looking for it
there
This was
Troitsky
Alexei Troitsky
one of the most famous
study composers.
Damn
was he
was he Russian?
Yeah
so he was
he worked as a forester
like he
he lived in the wilderness
and
he wasn't a chess player
but all he did
is compose studies
and some of his like
most famous studies
are involved
like chasing a queen
around the board.
Wait really?
That's so cool.
Yeah
Troitsky's awesome.
What was his chess elo?
I would estimate
if he sat
I don't even know
if he has any games
in the database
probably like
you know
Damn
can you send me
can you spell his name
out in our chat
so I can look up
some of his studies later?
Yeah
so it's T-R-O
it spells several
different ways
because it's
but the most common
English spelling
is T-R-O-I-T
T-Z-K
No
his first name
was not Leon
it was Alexei
Wait
no I or Y
at the end?
No I or Y
well there is a Y
T-R-O
Tro
I
T-Z-K-Y
Troitsky
Okay
Got it
If you search that
in Google
you'll find a bunch of
you'll find a bunch
of studies
Okay cool
That's
that's a pretty
pretty cool history
So
but what's amazing
about this one
is how you
you literally
go on the same squares
like you go
to B8 to H8
then to H8
and to B8
Yeah
no this was
a very beautiful study
So
awesome
Yeah
Troitsky's studies
are great
Unbelievable
He would use
the term cheating
That's true
So
Well there's
Okay
There is one
that caught my eye
which I feel like
has the potential
to be beautiful
and it's a
it's a minor piece
endgame
wanna tackle that one
and then maybe
we can go to
middle games
Yeah let's do it
let's do it
I really do like
endgame studies
so I'm down
No and they're very
again I think
a lot of people
when they do studies
at this point
I think
it teaches you
a lot of skills
it's not all about
solving positions
that are gonna
happen in your game
none of the positions
you solve
are gonna happen
in the game
So
I'm a big believer
in studies
I've done
thousands of them
I thought you were
gonna have
some extra line
at the end
about why
it's still important
but you were just like
yeah they're
not gonna happen
in the game
Nope